okay continuing to catch up about the
press briefings then we're going to move
on to some other stuff unbelievable
video for you today during yesterday's
press briefing Donald Trump again
started talking about masks and 95
respirator masks are in short supply the
less protecting basic surgical masks are
also in short supply sorts or supplies
short supply that's difficult to say
so Trump floated the idea without any
evidence yesterday that he's skeptical
about some of the none of the numbers
that hospitals say they need of these
masks and he suggested without evidence
that maybe they are effectively falling
off of the backs of trucks using other
language to suggest what are hospitals
doing with these masks are they stealing
the masks so as an example a healthcare
CEO said during yesterday's press
briefing you know there's a hospital we
deal with they usually use 10 to 20,000
masks a month
they now need 200 to 300,000 masks per
month and Trump's reaction was are some
going out the back door are these being
stolen
Trump was confused about why so many
masks were being used for years 10 to
20,000 masks okay it's a New York
Hospital very it's packed all the time
how do you go from 10 to 20 to 300,000
10 to 20,000 masks to 300,000 even
though this is different
something's going on and you ought to
look into it as reporters wear the masks
going are they going out the back door
how do you go from 10,000 to 300,000 and
we have that in a lot of different
places so somebody should probably look
into that because I just don't see from
a practical standpoint how that's
possible to go from that to that and we
have that happening in numerous places
Trump is incredulous about the increase
he says something must be going on there
yes what's going on is coronavirus they
need the masks they're using the masks
every time you do one coronavirus test
that uses a mask New York has
the thousand cases that 60,000 asks to
do those tests every time you interact
with a patient in the ER that's a mask
the nurse the doctor the person who
checks you into the hospital the x-ray
tech is likely using a mask at this
point in time it's masks every time and
Trump is suggesting maybe there's not
really a shortage meaning he did nothing
wrong remember all of this is meant to
say he did nothing wrong someone else
did something wrong
maybe hospitals are stealing masks which
shifts the blame from him once again to
somebody else look at how simple the
math is though imagine a hospital with a
couple hundred nurses and a couple
hundred kovat patients per day you're
using the masks as directed imagine in
one day you know 100 of those couple
hundred of nurses that the hospital may
have are working or whatever hundred
patients hundreds of nurses three
interactions per day 30 days that's a
million masks right there now of course
that's an over estimate they're
rationing the masks they probably aren't
you know the full slate of nurses isn't
working every day there's shift there's
the rotation okay but you get the idea
300,000 masks is very realistic it would
even sound low considering that you've
got hospitals that are huge that have
other things going on you do an
appendectomy that comes in that needs to
be done you've got an anesthesiologist
and a surgeon and a nurse that's five
masks right there but Trump's instinct
is it can't possibly be that I screwed
up it can't possibly be that I fail to
get anybody masks maybe masks are
falling off the back of the truck in
other words being stolen by workers it's
not just incredibly disgusting and
immoral but it is another sign of what
dr. Justin Frank has been telling us the
inability to ever take responsibility
the inability to ever say I may have
been slow on something is part of the
slate of disorders that dr. Justin Frank
and many other mental health
professionals believe Donald Trump is
suffering from we're going to get to
that later in the meantime if you're not
following me on Instagram
I've been keeping my Instagram light and
I have some very funny I have a mattress
faceplant video on my Instagram that is
distracting people for like 10 seconds
from the crisis we're dealing with check
it out it's on my Instagram at David
Pakman follow the show on Instagram
while you're there at David Pakman show
coming up next is the virus a germ a flu
or what Trump still doesn't know I'd
love it if you checked out a YouTube
channel we're partnering with their
content is great and they're good
friends of the David Pakman show the
channel is called up flip and you can
get there at david pakman.com slash up
flip make sure you subscribe when you're
there if you own your own business if
you're thinking of starting one if
you're interested in entrepreneurship
and building companies as many of you
know I am I think you will love this
because every week up flip gives you
sort of an inside look at a successful
small business how did the entrepreneur
do it how was it built from the ground
up the stories are inspiring I always
love learning about how business owners
got to where they are and they share a
ton of wisdom about mistakes what they
learned really great insights and up
flip up loads new videos every Wednesday
featuring a totally new business check
it out at david pakman.com slash up flip
link is right down below underneath this
video subscribe to their channel and
click that Bell icon to get
notifications